184 pays sont touchés plus de 1 million
500 mille personnes sont malades ducobu
de 19
s'il est important de signaler que trois
cent quarante mille personnes sont
guéris nous déplorons plus de 90 mille
morts dans le monde
les etats unis sont le pays le plus
touché avec plus de 430 3000 cas
l'europe reste l'épicentre de la
pandémie avec 725 milka et plus de
soixante mille morts
l'espagne observe un plateau avec 153
milles cas en italie l'épidémie entamé
une très lente régression avec près de
140 mille cas l'allemagne à plus de 113
milka et plus de 2300 morts ainsi que le
royaume-uni 61000 cas et près de 8000
morts sont encore en phase ascendante et
on peut noter ce soir que trois pays
déplore plus de quinze mille décès c'est
le cas des états unis de l'espagne et de
l'italie qui a plus de 18000 d'essai en
france nous sommes confrontés à une
situation exceptionnelle qui s'inscrit
dans la durée
tous ensemble nous devons faire bloc
contre le virus
la maladie l'épidémie respecter le
confinement
la distanciation physique de plus d'un
mètre
tous les gestes barrières et la
réduction volontaire et massive des
contacts grâce à ces mesures
nous sommes en train progressivement de
freiner l'épidémie pour diminuer encore
la pression sur tous nos établissements
de santé sur nos médecins nos infirmiers
nous aide soignant qui sont en tension
maximale qui travaillent jour et nuit
nous devons tous ensemble redoubler nos
efforts collectifs et solidaire ce soir
1114 établissements de santé font état
de près de soixante deux mille six cent
quarante et une hospitalisation depuis
le début d'épidémie vous imaginez donc
le poids de cette épidémie sur l'hôpital
ce soir 30 1767 p
sohn sont encore hospitalisés pour une
infection qu'ovide 19 en 24 heures ce
sont près de 3000 personnes qui sont
entrées à l'hôpital cela représente
encore une hausse encore un solde
positif 392 malades de plus à prendre en
charge par rapport à hier ce qui montre
la dynamique la cinétique de cette
épidémie 7060 6 patients graves
nécessite des soins de réanimation
c'est évidemment très supérieur aux
capacités initiales de la réanimation
française qui était je vous le rappel de
5000 places en réanimation 33 % de ces
patients ont moins de 60 ans et 61 % ont
entre 60 et 80 ans ont des comptes 105
personnes hospitalisées en réanimation
qui ont moins de 30 ans et donc dans
certaines situations les jeunes peuvent
être touchés gravement au cours des
dernières 24 heures 3 169 nouveaux
patients ont été admis en réanimation
c'est encore très importants le solde
la différence entre les entrées et les
sorties qui représente donc le nombre
total de patients à prendre
en plus chaque jour et pour la première
fois faiblement négatif de 82 patients
c'est donc une très légère diminution
des besoins de réanimation ce besoin de
trouver de nouvelles places de nouvelles
équipes de nouvelles machines diminuent
pour la première fois on peut donc
espérer un plateau mais c'est un plateau
très haut et il faut rester extrêmement
prudent
ceci nécessite évidemment d'être
confirmée dans les jours à venir
cette tension sur les équipes de
réanimation les hôpitaux est très
inégale et certaines régions ont encore
besoin de transférer des patients graves
demain de nouveaux tgv médicalisé
transféreront des patientes grave de
réanimation de la région ile de france
vers la région nouvelle aquitaine